i spend all day looking at
radicalization pathways and
the worst possible things that can
happen online in terms of tracking
my biggest concern this time isn't uh
russian interference in the election
it's american mobilizations at polling
places
threats of violence in terms of counting
or ballots or ballot boxes
election security officials and
academics say misinformation
and disinformation have never been more
of a threat to the u.s election
especially as coronavirus concerns breed
more confusion around the voting process
from misleading text messages to false
social media posts shared by
seemingly trusted sources bad actors are
targeting many groups
and often the researchers tracking the
content find themselves
scrambling to keep up with those
spreading the false or misleading
information
the researchers slag it to the platforms
which also have their own monitoring
services
what's at stake for the 2020
presidential election
what's the worst that could happen if
misinformation runs rampant
what are we opening ourselves up to how
are we normalizing the ingestion of
information
in quick 10 slide instagram stories
isabella garcia camargo
is a cyber security researcher at
stanford working on a coalition
focused on detecting and mitigating
misinformation
during the election even a year ago a
lot of people if you talked about q and
on
nobody really knew what it was since
cobit though and since
the huge change in kind of the
information landscape that came from
that the movement has really grown over
the past couple of months and we're
seeing it
pop up internationally even now the fbi
has identified q anon as a potential
domestic terrorism threat
the far right wing loosely organized
network is one of the conspiracy theory
groups
that has gained traction since social
distancing forced
many people to more frequently interact
online
and it's not just online platforms
misinformation is spreading more through
text messages or digital television ads
especially as social media firms crack
down on such content
i think it's important to recognize that
more and more young people are getting
their news from picked off getting their
news from instagram
people are isolated and they are trying
to figure out the world
from a digital feed what that digital
feed is being manipulated or bombarded
with false information or being
distorted through paid advertisements it
makes it very difficult for people to
understand what's going on
clint watts is a former fbi special
agent and a distinguished fellow
at the foreign policy research institute
studying social media influence
election security experts like clint say
inaccurate voter or polling information
could mean some miss their chance to
vote while social media giants like
facebook and twitter now have more
stringent policies against content that
could suppress
voters security officials are still
worried about the damage done before
misinformation
is labeled or removed conspiracies that
claim mail-in ballots aren't counted
could dissuade some voters
and questions about the validity of
election results could threaten the
future of politics in america
unless one candidate will have an unfair
advantage or the other one will it's
more like just generally
mistrust in the outcome from the losing
side
um or from any side here if we start to
erode the trust that we have
in our democratic principles and in our
democratic system
i think that that has very very
long-term consequences
i want people to know that their vote
counted and want them to have confidence
in that
misinformation has already spread in
this election cycle
the legitimacy of mail-in ballots has
been questioned by some
and in august a number of florida voters
received a spoofed text message
alleging rep byron donalds was dropping
out of a congressional race
soon after donald tweeted that the text
message shared false information
and he in fact was not dropping out if
you continue to pump disinformation
through the social media machine and
social media
doesn't regulate to a degree like what
is actual verifiable truth uh
let's deep fix continue those sorts of
things well
everyone loses at the end the companies
fall into a
collapsing state the politicians can't
advance policy and
voters are just sort of left hanging in
the balance every single time that you
post something to your story
that you like a tweet your interactions
are like a vote in this space
the most patriotic thing you can do is
to just think a little bit before you
like
or you tweet before you share things